>>> AS THE DELTA VARIANT IS
RAGING ACROSS THE U.S., THE
NATION REMAINS DIVIDED BETWEEN
STATES FIGHTING THE VIRUS AND
STATES FIGHTING THE SCIENCE.
STATES LED BY POLITICIANS WHO
KNOW BETTER.
CASE IN POINT, FLORIDA.
>> WHAT IS HE SO UPSET ABOUT
FLORIDA?
HIS SOLUTION IS HE WANTS TO HAVE
THE GOVERNMENT FORCE
KINDERGARTENERS TO WEAR MASKS IN
SCHOOL.
>> FLORIDA'S REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR, RON DeSANTIS, IS
BARRING SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE FROM ENACTING MASK
MANDATES.
NEVER MIND THAT CONSERVATIVES
TEND TO SUPPORT LOCAL CONTROL
OVER THEIR SCHOOLS, THAT'S ONLY
PART OF THE PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT FLORIDA HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE LEADERS IN THE
U.S. IN COVID CASES.
JUST AS KIDS TOO YOUNG TO BE
VACCINATED ARE HEADING BACK TO
THE CLASSROOM.
THE DELTA VARIANT IS SLAMMING
STATES WHERE VACCINATION STATES
ARE LAGGING BEHIND MUCH OF THE
COUNTRY.
THE MAP IS VERY CLEAR THERE.
ONE OF THOSE DELTA HOT SPOTS IS
MISSOURI, WHERE SENATOR JOSH
HAWLEY HAS BEEN GOING AFTER THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR
REQUIRING VACCINATIONS FOR
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES.
>> WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS JOE
BIDEN AND THE LEFT USING A
CAMPAIGN OF FEAR AND
INTIMIDATION IN ORDER TO TRY TO
KEEP THE COUNTRY IN A PERPETUAL
STATE OF CRISIS AND CENTRALIZE
CONTROL AND POWER OVER PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
>> HE SEEMED OKAY WITH FEAR AND
INTIMIDATION ON JANUARY 6th, BUT
I DIGRESS.
HAWLEY UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE VACCINE.
HE'S ALREADY GOTTEN HIS.
THE BIG REASON FOR VACCINES FOR
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES, OF COURSE, IS
THAT VACCINATION RATES ARE TOO
LOW TO END THE PANDEMIC IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE ARE NOW DEALING WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF OUR ACTIONS.
THE VIRUS MUTATED INTO THE DELTA
VARIANT, WHICH IS NOW UNLEASHING
MISERY ALL OVER THE U.S.
HOSPITALS ARE FILLING UP.
THE NUMBER OF DEAD RISING AGAIN.
SO, YES, GOVERNMENTS,
CORPORATIONS, THEY'RE REQUIRING
VACCINATIONS.
YES, SOME LOCAL LEADERS ARE
CALLING ON MASKS TO RETURN SO
KIDS CAN SAFELY GO BACK TO
SCHOOL, SO WE CAN PREVENT MORE
LOCKDOWNS.
AS THIS PANDEMIC GRINDS ON, OUR
TOP SCIENTISTS WARN THE VIRUS
COULD MUTATE INTO OTHER
VARIANTS.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI SAYS THE NEXT
VARIANT COULD BE MORE CONTAGIOUS
AND MORE LETHAL.
>> YOU MAY SOONER OR LATER GET
ANOTHER VARIANT.
AND IT IS POSSIBLE THAT THAT
VARIANT MIGHT BE IN SOME
RESPECTS WORSE THAN THE ALREADY
VERY DIFFICULT VARIANT WE'RE
DEALING WITH NOW.
>> WORSE THAN THE VARIANT WE'RE
IT MAKES SENSE THEN, THAT SOME
IN THE GOP HAVE REGRETS.
GOVERNOR ASA HUTCHINSON OF
ARKANSAS SAYS HE NOW WISHES HE
HADN'T SIGNED A LAW BACK IN
APRIL PREVENTING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FROM ENACTING
THEIR OWN MASK MANDATES.
>> AND, YES, IN HINDSIGHT I WISH
THAT HAD NOT BECOME LAW.
BUT IT IS THE LAW.
THE ONLY CHANCE WE HAVE IS
EITHER TO AMEND IT OR FOR THE
COURTS TO SAY THAT IT HAS AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FOUNDATION.
>> SOME REPUBLICANS HAVE MORE
THAN JUST REGRETS.
SOUTH CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN RALPH
NORMAN TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID.
NORMAN AND HIS GOP COLLEAGUE,
CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, HAVE SUED HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI OVER MASKING
REQUIREMENTS UP ON CAPITOL HILL.
OTHER REPORTS ARE COMING IN
ABOUT GOP POLITICIANS DYING FROM
COVID COMPLICATIONS AFTER THEY
MOCKED VACCINATIONS.
AND SPEAKING OF GREENE, LISTEN
TO WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY ABOUT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS GOING DOOR
TO DOOR ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
GET VACCINATED.
>> IN THE SOUTH, WE ALL LOVE OUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
AND WE'RE NOT REAL BIG ON
STRANGERS SHOWING UP ON OUR
FRONT DOOR, ARE WE?
THEY MIGHT NOT LIKE THE WELCOME
THEY GET.
>> DeSANTIS HAS PUT HIS OWN
STAMP IN THIS ANTI-SCIENCE
CRUSADE.
BASHING DR. FAUCI.
SELLING KOOZIES AND T-SHIRTS
THAT SAY DON'T FAUCI MY FLORIDA.
DeSANTIS HAD THIS TO SAY TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO URGED GOP
GOVERNORS TO GET OUT OF THE WAY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S COVID
EFFORTS.
>> SO WHY DON'T YOU DO YOUR JOB.
WHY DON'T YOU GET THIS BORDER
SECURE.
AND UNTIL YOU DO THAT, I DON'T
WANT TO HEAR A BLIP ABOUT COVID
FROM YOU.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE BORDER?
IT SOUNDS LIKE I KNOW YOU ARE,
BUT WHAT AM I?
WHAT'S NEXT?
I'M RUBBER AND YOU'RE GLUE?
NANA BOO BOO?
NOT EXACTLY A JFK PROFILE IN
COURAGE MOMENT.
MORE LIKE SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY
OF LOUISIANA, ANOTHER DELTA
VARIANT HOT SPOT.
THAT SENATOR KENNEDY RECENTLY
TOLD PEOPLE IN HIS STATE TO
VACCINATE OR DON'T VACCINATE.
WHATEVER.
>> WE NEED TO SPEND ALL OF OUR
EFFORTS TRYING TO CONVINCE FOLKS
THAT THE COSTS OF THE VACCINE
ARE SUBSTANTIALLY LESS THAN THE
BENEFIT.
LET ME SAY IT AGAIN.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE
VACCINE, DON'T TAKE IT.
>> DON'T TAKE IT?
HOLD ON.
THESE POLITICIANS, THEY KNOW
BETTER.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
DeSANTIS IS A GRADUATE OF
HARVARD LAW AND YALE.
HAWLEY WENT TO YALE LAW AND
STANFORD.
KENNEDY STUDIED AT OXFORD, UVA
AND VANDERBILT.
ANYBODY WHO'S GONE TO AN ELITE
UNIVERSITY NOT ONLY PASSED A
SCIENCE CLASS, BUT SHOULD ALSO
VALUE EXPERTISE AND THE EXPERTS
ARE TELLING US TO LISTEN TO THE
SCIENCE.
THAT IT'S BETTER TO BE
VACCINATED.
THAT MASKS WILL HELP IN AREAS
WHERE COVID RATES ARE SOARING.
AND YET SOME OF THESE GOP
LEADERS WON'T SAY THE SCIENCE
PART OUT LOUD.
JUST THE OTHER DAY, AND WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS THIS
AFTERNOON, AN 11-MONTH-OLD GIRL
IN TEXAS, ANOTHER HARD-HIT
STATE, HAD TO BE FLOWN 150 MILES
AWAY FOR TREATMENT BECAUSE
HOSPITAL BEDS ARE FULL IN HER
TOWN.
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO DIE SO
SOME POLITICIANS CAN OWN THE
LIBS.
THEY'RE NOT OWNING ANYBODY.
BUT THEY MAY END UP OWNING THE
PANDEMIC, BECAUSE THEY'RE
PROLONGING IT.
PERHAPS IT'S TIME TO START
NAMING THESE NEW VARIANTS THAT
MAY BE COMING OUT AFTER THEM
INSTEAD OF THE DELTA VARIANT.
WHY NOT CALL IT THE DeSANTIS
VARIANT?
WE COULD SELL BEER KOOZIES THAT
SAY DON'T FLORIDA MY FAUCI.
AND USE